listen this thing only goes to 11 so
beat it spider-man waiting for Celine to
get an Oscar nom what the heck is this I
cannot hit the notes of Celine Dion but
anyway ah hey guys everybody's talking
about the Oscar nobs the snubs surprises
but the hill that I would love to die on
is the fact that Celine Dion's
ashes the song from Deadpool - did not
get nominated a crime a crime are we
okay with this clearly not joining me
today is Celine Dion enthusiast and
regal Queen yes it says that in your
lower third a you I love your show thank
you for having me oh my god thanks for
being here yes we're doing the whole
episode about Celine Dion not getting up
nominate for an Oscar are we okay with
it absolutely not you see the expression
on my face Celine Dion is everything
that award shows should be about and
this song was no exception it's big it's
powerful it's anthemic to not include
her like I said before it's a crime it's
a robbery and I think it's worth noting
that songwriters get the Oscar Awards
the Celine Dion didn't write the song
she wouldn't actually get the award she
doesn't have an Oscar my heart will go
on not written by her beating the beats
not right not by her but all the
nominated songs have performances so
what we were robbed of was a Celine Dion
performance at the Oscars which is not
appropriate another crime would I have
notified the authorities do you want to
watch an award show if Celine is not
performing I don't think I do really I
don't really want to watch anything
period of Celine Dion's not easy but I
will make exceptions from time to time
right rare exceptions but like a Celine
performance like Celine wearing Couture
mo man belting this song on stage you
know Ryan Reynolds would have somehow
been involved yes he would have I don't
have the flexibility that's in the video
we had something new today I think it's
a crime we it would be magnetic to see
her on that stage she's done it before
okay she did the performance with the
Beauty and the Beast crew and then
type that song from Titanic I think this
would have been like a really nice
trifecta to round it all out but I will
say I did drink two bottles of wine and
go to her Vegas show where she did
perform action it's fine no of course I
did um where she did that ah we drink
shall we go for it
yes um where she did perform ashes and
it was incredible really like like TV
goose buns yes and she sounds a little
like she's like kind of a stand-up
comedian she tells little stories
between she thought she was gonna be
cast as the love interest but then he
was right the song she was I
disappointed but that she did anyway and
she gave the best performance of her
lifetime during every single song
because girl Prince's that's what she
does day in and day out
she's just Thailand in heaven I like to
say there's three people in life that we
should respect whatever Lord or like
power that you worship your mother and
Celine Dion yes no I would like to add
share to their that category 100% I like
to add Britney Spears pick your own
poison yeah um I just think that the
Academy typically favors someone like
Celine Dion who's like a true artist
such an amazing singer and to snub a
song with great lyrics great melody
powerful quality you know I'm truly
confused I also want to mention so [ __ ]
it's up when they were campaigning for
Delta because they were on that whole
like we are on the campaign trail right
that song wasn't listed in there for
your consideration on this site and you
should be yeah talking directly to you
Fox please let me still interview your
people like I love you guys but it's
weird you have Celine Dion I would be
shouting that from the mountaintops hey
Sally Sally Sally Sally Hank this is one
of those songs to where you think oh is
it maybe because it's from kind of a
campy ER movie yeah it kind of a
tongue-in-cheek song that it wouldn't be
considered but then I remember I drank
all my water um better remember that uh
bland Canada from South Park the movie
was nominated and performed by Robin
Williams at the Oscars one hundred
percent of solid point I think you kind
of have to break it down like a
year-by-year and look at how many people
are really like contenders or in
contention for this award and this was a
really solid here you've got Kendrick
Lamar you've got Lady gaga you've got a
diane warren song right it's like a
staff
category but it's like Celine Dion is a
stacked artist well I gotta say I mean
looking at these songs get because it is
that it is that conversation of like oh
whoa who would you remove but then I'm
like after all the stars and and and
shallow both huge songs right okay and
then diane warren one of the most
decorated songwriters in all of music
period I think she's been in this
category I think ten times since she's
never won so I think she's totally
deserving to win that's a fair point
okay um the one song that I'm not a
hundred percent in love with is when a
cowboy trades his Spurs for wings uh
it's a little campy it's it's a good
song it's just not my taste personally
well this is the thing I heard this song
and I was like this is not for me at all
but then I looked at the the up boats on
YouTube people loved it yeah I got huge
audience oh there's 100% an audience for
it and you never know just remember when
on it's hard out there for a pimp one at
the Oscars yeah I remember their
reaction of sitting in my living room
with my parents we were like what what
is this song like songs like this that
sometimes are just completely shocking
to some are like a complete shoo-in for
others right so it really could be I
think it's gonna be stars born but I
think it could be anybody's game what
I'm just most upset about is that Celine
is not gonna be performing we're not
gonna get to see her in couture it's a
really missed opportunity
yeah yeah and you know that she would
feather sparkles something would just be
iconic and looking at this category too
there are some other songs I wish we're
considered like thinking about that
spider-verse soundtrack that was iconic
from start to finish and not one of
those songs made this cut is criminal to
me almost as criminal as Celine and
there's there's like that any movie
hearts beat loud they have their bear
song in there that I think is so just
amazing one of the best songs of the
year period while I wasn't even
considered sound up please sound up
please
[Music]
doesn't sound up that was sounded it was
a sound up um so yeah I know you guys
are like why are you talking about this
and there's so many great nominees but
my heart will always go on for sell or
saline just don't rob me of a Celine
Dion moment ever again too into it I
don't know I'm talking too but don't do
it again
I hope the Celine Dion stands are with
us oh yes that that's the thing is yes I
did make a whole episode surrounded
about Celine Dion not being at the
Oscars but this is the hill that are
willing to die on I'm not okay with it I
will sit and lie next to you yes do you
guys agree how do you feel are you like
why are you talking about this let me
know in the comments I'm a - Crossin
where can everybody talk to you at
Deidre Behar thanks so much for watching
today cuz I'm okay with the void I love
you know Celine to Celine
[Music]
[Applause]